-It is time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since tomorrow's
Thanksgiving
and people will be spending
a lot of time in the kitchen,
we sent out the...
...where I asked you guys
to tweet out a funny
or embarrassing story that
happened to you in the kitchen.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
[ Cheering and applause ]
so thank you for playing along.
[ Whistling ]
I appreciate that.
It's always so much fun.
Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
#CookingFail responses
from you guys.
This first one here is
from @DianaDee16.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just like the original
Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Bonenibbler.
Um --
[ Laughter ]
@Bonenibbler.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
Just, why?
-It's protein.
-Just, why, right?
-Yeah, exactly, man.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @acstucker.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
My mother really liked
making this.
[ Sputtering ]
Doing!
This one's from @abbey-joyner12.
She says...
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
It's not that quick
mac & cheese.
Come on, man.
Although, I do think the
microwave's ready for an update.
-Yeah.
-I don't think it's fast enough.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, out of nothing,
the "microwave" concept is
sort of obsolete, at this point.
-No, I think the concept,
I get that, right?
I still think the idea, it's
a faster way of cooking, but --
-Yeah.
-You know.
-You want yours
like "Jetsons" fast.
-Yeah, I mean, popcorn
is three minutes.
It's just too much.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think
would be apropos?
-I'm going to say, uh...
20 seconds.
-Oof!
Wow.
-Pop.
Actually, it should be
as fast as the word "pop."
One second.
-Wow.
-You got a bag of popcorn.
-That's crazy. I don't know
that I would eat that stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
-I need at least, you know,
like two,
three minutes on the pop.
-What are you talking
about, man?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not just consuming,
you know, 1.1-second popcorn
all willy-nilly.
-No, I'm talking about, me, you,
snuggled up with a little
fleece over us...
[ Laughter ]
-...watching some
"Gilmore Girls" bloopers.
-Remember those blankets
with like the hand --
the arm openings?
-Snuggies?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm talking me, you...
-Me, you, one --
-couple Snuggies.
-No, one Snuggie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals clash ]
-Come on, man, you don't care
about the popcorn,
at that point.
Come on.
It's just about the experience.
-Yeah, man.
Tandem Snuggies.
[ Laughter ]
-Tandem Snuggies,
that could've been something.
-Yeah.
-Anyways,
microwave people,
get on that, man.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @cindihuston.
She says...
-Aah!
-Ouch!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
Aaaaah!
-It is around the same
size, man.
[ Laughter ]
The old Bonenibbler.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm familiar, very familiar,
yeah, yeah.
This one's from @RobinStur.
She says...
[ Audience murmuring ]
[ Laughter ]
-And a new daughter.
-Yeah, no, that's crazy, right?
I remember that thing though,
that self-cleaning button.
Some metal latch you go
[ Cluck ]
and that was the end of it, man.
It didn't work.
-That's what needs
to be updated.
You need to be able to like
stop the self-cleaning mode,
once you press that button.
-No, I think
that has been invented.
-Really?
-Sure.
-Maybe my oven is just antique.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have an antique oven?
-Yeah. I mean, I don't think
it's been invented, man.
You just don't know ovens.
[ Laughter ]
-I figured that's been invented.
I don't have to worry this
stuff, self-cleaning ovens.
That whole thin, you know what?
I'll let other people deal
with that stuff.
I'm talking about --
[ Scat singing ]
Zzzhzzhzzhzzh....
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I got things
happening, man.
I can't wait this long.
-Right.
-Yeah.
[ Pop ]
Thank you.
Popcorn's ready.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you go, "Dude, we got
to celebrate tonight."
[ Pop ]
And we're going to make popcorn.
Thank you, Fred.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Three seconds.
-You know what?
That took too long.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @ninja-natasha.
She said...
Look at this thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...